hey Jack nation Greg Alva here longtime
buddy of Greg is here Ashley you've seen
the first Karate Kid I just saw and she
did not know this but YouTube read has
released a show called Cobra Kai which
is a sequel of sorts it picks up 30
years later with Danny and Johnny
Lawrence the guy who swept the leg
oh he's in it yeah and then his wrath
and then there's the Karate Kid himself
and they're in it what happened to now
he's in Cobra Kai decided he's back in
action we're gonna watch the first
episode I think we can only show about
ten minutes of this on YouTube which I
would have to cut up the reaction
portion we could probably put the
full-length one over on our patreon ten
minute version here we'll talk about it
I've seen Karate Kid one in three and I
saw that about 15 years ago I have not
been a person who rewatch is the Karate
Kid a [ __ ] yeah it's not that fresh in
my mind I remember the finale and
certain famous moment before we do that
I want to give a page from the day shout
out to James Dagon's because James
Sagan's and I brought him up and brought
up Ashley and a Google hangout he was
like he's got a crush on Ashley
so Ashley can you say something nice to
james Dagon's and we hope you enjoyed
this reaction video I hope so too if you
ever come to California Ashley told me
herself she will leave whomever she's
dating to spend time with you let's go
play some mini golf yes
Ashley's favorite thing to do and she
said she would kiss you unless you're
not gonna golf then maybe
she keeps it real watch this 1 2 3
yay that's two days after Ashley's
birthday I do that move in street fights
all the time okay oh how could he not
see that cake coming it's such like a
prepped cake like what other king what
do you do Wow he's older by 30 years how
weird
how lonely I was just Burbank
I live off there and I just gave away a
big thing the Russo Auto Group is a car
company la girls why are you all like
that gonna have to bring out his karate
skills oh snap it's just like Wolverine
[Laughter]
Oh now's your chance go go mr. Miyagi on
them that was this pizza man is the new
mr. Miyagi mystery argue beats of
teenagers in the first one and it's like
whatever first on the that was one of my
dad's best friends see me a couple years
mom what seemed the first one
[Music]
how to see that I love alcoholics and
movies who are like is still in good
shape I have a feeling Danny's gonna die
Dan's gonna come back and like the very
end of this episode yes Danny Larusso
that's a Ralph Macchio oh [ __ ] what's he
gonna do yeah
but the first cry this is cool it's like
that water moment in the tournament just
like and he has to watch this guy live
off the success
[Music]
this guy needs to watch the secret
[Laughter]
[Music]
really portrays everyone in LA as a dick
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I like the switcheroo how like he seems
like I'm like a dick it's on the house
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna be your sensei
oh it's now that firm of the beer strike
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when I see movies in New York and how
they portray people on the streets in
New York yeah but in New York they can
definitely be that way it's not like
this morning noon or something like that
on the road if anything yeah everyone
seems so mean in here and I I don't
really see that that's kind of like I
mean if you look at like an 80s movie
like they're trying yeah yeah yeah like
they're always like that like the kids
at school or like something like bullies
I kind of think that they were bringing
that sort of like oh that's sure that's
a good way to put it and I like the role
reversal too that is the Karate Kid
story of mr. Miyagi saves Danny from
high school bullies beats them up yeah
and it's like okay I mean it starts the
rivalry and all that but he's beating
him up my first thought is he's picking
up the context feels so different but
then nowadays you're like that's just
wrong he goes to jail for self-awareness
seem to be at the right pitch throughout
the whole lot especially for only what
was it 27 minutes was good it was great
they put a lot in there and
you know and then I like how the girl
for the daughter her boyfriend looks
like it's gonna be the kid who got yeah
the whole karate kids story mr. Miyagi
feels for Danny Larusso wants to teach
him and help him out and then here his
whole reasoning for starting the school
uh purely selfish yeah he'll evolve into
a character then I think he's gonna get
his life together and then he might end
up getting back with yeah because they
did tease there's a kid on the 2010 song
he had a kid yeah it seems like they set
up a lot of room for growth and they're
treating this like a real show instead
of just like nostalgia Karate Kid and
the guys are like still good actors you
know sometimes you see like kid actors
and really good no they they got the
tone of the show right like that these
were the performances were solid that
would be nice that would be a biggest
surprise I am genuinely surprised by how
good I thought this was it's like I was
I was really surprised I was like as is
probably gonna be fun for like just
hardcore Karate Kid fans but like I want
to watch yeah it helps watching the
first movie but like you haven't seen
the first movie in so long and like you
understood oh yeah yeah yeah I think
they're aware there's gonna have to be
some new people they're gonna bring in a
whole bunch of new stuff and a whole
bunch of familiarity I'm very happy this
this is because now I'm hooked I'm like
I want to see the rest of the show yeah
I'll text you my updates I'll spoil
every episode it's gotta get a YouTube
ready yeah alright guys well thanks for
watching along Ashley thanks for
convening to this with us you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about get notified
every time when our vids is up you could
check out we had to do full-length TV
show reactions over at our patreon as
well as weekly Q&A is plenty of shows
we're watching and please make sure to
check out a sh t editor on instagram and
of course her youtube channel as well
that's the only way I get her to come
back this friendship means nothing
- this woman that's right even though I
do have your ten-year-old photo of you
gonna cry why do you have a photo so
long ago and I come to get my wallet for
such a long time
literally he's like 10 years old a
little karate but it's so cute I don't
amazing if I would have brought it or if
you had it for this I mean I have photos
if you know what I might have it
somewhere and then you can like put it
in here somehow we'll take care you guys